MainActivity is launched
when you start the app.
At the bottom of MainActivity,
we have PlaceholderFragment.
PlaceholderFragment was generated
by the template we used
when creating our project.
A fragment is a modular container
within your activity.
In later lessons, we'll look at how
to use multiple fragments
in a single activity.
And we'll actually explain why,
we're using them at all.
But for now, our activity contains
just this one fragment.
So here in PlaceholderFragment,
is where we reference
our UI layout resource,
called fragment main.
This XML file lives in the Resource's
RES directory of our Project Folder.
You can see other kinds of resources
here besides layouts,
such as design assets
or drawables, or strings.
When our activity runs,
it creates this placeholder
fragment which then inflates
the XML layout resource,
converting everything in the XML file
to a hierarchy of view objects in memory.
By holding CTRL or CMD,
depending on your operating system,
and clicking on this reference
to fragment main.
Android studio will drop us
right into the visual layout editor.
Once we're inside a layout XML file,
we can switch between the design tab,
where we can drag and drop new
UI elements
and modify the layout visually.
And the Text tab, where we can see
and edit the XML that defined the layout
and UI elements.
All of the views we'll talk about here
ultimately extend the view base class.
The template we used gives us
a relative layout, with some padding
around the edges.
We'll get into layout features
like padding and margins, later.
Inside our relative layout,
is a single TextView that says,
hello world.
EditText, is a text entry field
that is an editable version of text view.
It has many options, such as
whether it supports single or multi line.
There are several styled versions
of editText, in the text field section
of android studio,
such as Name, E-mail,
Phone, or Postal Address
Each one sets the soft keyboard
into an appropriate entry mode.
ImageView displays the image
defined in its source attribute.
It has some really useful features,
like zooming and cropping
if the source file is too large
or has a different aspect ratio
than the image view itself.
A list view is a special kind
of view that contains one
or more view that are replicated
to display sets of data.
In this case, this single textView
is used to display
the weather information replicated
throughout the list.
We'll get into much more detail
about list view later on.